can't afford to get yo kids in fella
trouble tonight as he picks up his first
now klay Thompson it's one thing the
bees win for the face double team comes
down dumps it in to Durant at the
current sidestepping
is the best road record in the West now
Thompson's loose City knocks it in
wheezing he's getting worse not when it
runs into the scripts first bucket
Nikola averaging almost 20 points a game
then Thompson's that it's better get
real here in terms of K Y P know your
personnel as the Nuggets play here in
the first period
Durant lets it go that's good with game
faces off good but will that work or not
Lou T's inside Martin almost has left
wide open ball ball in the bull January
averaging just two and a half points per
game and shooting is curry from way way
out see that's that's all you get curry
to take a tough shot falling out of
boundary pointless
[Applause]
[Music]
finding side steps again Rudy's on fire
Steph Curry full of six the night and
former delete old nugget scores the
words already have three and double
figures man their burden up the nets